hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new oneplus 9 pro and today we are
putting it up
against the iphone 12 pro max to see
which one is the better phone now i have
to be real with you guys the last time
we compared a oneplus
to an iphone the oneplus honestly got
smoked so this time
i saw that oneplus made huge
improvements and i'm excited to compare
the displays the speakers of course the
performance
the design of it and this hasselblad
logo that they're really trying to push
to see how they stack up
and going off of the specs i'm kind of
worried for the iphone but of course we
do
real world tests so let's get into it
now i typically don't focus on the box
but i have to show you guys
this monstrosity it is massive
compared to the iphone's box but that is
because
oneplus is thankfully not following the
trend
of getting rid of chargers instead
they are giving us let me get this thing
popped open this absolute
beast of a charger and cable 65 watts
warp charging
that can charge this phone with the 4500
milliamp hour battery
from zero to 100 in 30
minutes that is crazy now if you buy the
fastest charger for the iphone
it takes an hour and a half and of
course the battery capacity is
much smaller not only that but oneplus
is going crazy on wireless charging as
well
with this 50 watt wireless charger that
can charge up
this phone in about 43 to 45
minutes which is insane now of course
apple has their new mac safe technology
with 15 watts
but unfortunately instead of taking 45
minutes it takes
two hours to charge up the iphone 12 pro
max i do wish it was a little bit faster
but of course magsafe is not only
charging there's a lot of accessories
that we've recently made a video on
that really makes it quite useful and
handy other than
just charging as far as real world
battery life they are actually quite
similar in screen
on time that's if you have all the
high-end features
enabled on the oneplus and if you're
worried about battery degradation they
have made a lot of improvements
in precautions such as wattage lowering
down at night time where you don't need
super fast charging having dual
batteries things like that
to help with your battery longevity and
now let's get into the design and i want
you guys to let me know down in the
comment section
which one you think looks better now i
appreciate that both of them have
this matte kind of texture so they're
both very fingerprint resistant
as far as looks i do think that the
iphone looks a little bit more clean
although i do like the camera bump of
the oneplus it's just a little bit more
busy of course the iphone 12s now have
flat sides so
it looks more modern and a little bit
different compared to regular phones
like the oneplus
with their curved sides the 12 pros are
very prone to fingerprints so i keep
having to wipe it off where
this very thin frame on the oneplus 9
pro
you don't really notice any fingerprints
now both of them also have these
hardware switches
which i really like the oneplus actually
has a three position once you have a
little bit more control
now as far as comfort i have to give it
to the oneplus
it does feel more comfortable in the
hand and that is mostly because of
how much slimmer it is that is a
noticeable difference
it is slightly taller but that part you
won't really notice now the iphone does
feel more secure and grippy in the hand
because of the flat sides but it's less
comfortable flipping to the front we
have multiple differences
the oneplus has that curved glass edge
which i'm not the biggest fan of because
of glare
but it does make the phone look a little
bit more modern with thinner bezels the
iphone has completely flat
front the bezels are thicker but that
minimizes glare and i just prefer how it
feels overall
of course we have the ugly large notch
on the iphone compared to a small cutout
which i prefer for the oneplus now let's
get into authentication
with the iphone we have face id so you
just tap and swipe
logs you in pretty quick or you just
raise up your phone and then swipe
very convenient unless you're wearing a
mask that is
and with the oneplus we have the
underneath the display fingerprint
scanner it is nice and quick
but one thing compared to the samsung's
is you have to actually turn on the
display first either by having the
ambient rays to wake
or tapping the screen first or hitting
that side button in order to log
in now before we dig deep into all of
the display differences
i want to compare the speakers this is
an area where the oneplus
has been fairly weak in the past so i'm
curious to see
how they will compare go ahead and put
on a pair of headphones and let's take a
listen
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section
below and i have to say wow
that is a first in the past the oneplus
phones were always quieter than the
iphones
and they were much flatter not very rich
this time around the oneplus is
definitely louder
the mids sound a little bit more rich
they really stand out
the iphone does have a little bit
brighter highs and a little bit more
low end but it definitely is quieter so
this at least has to be a draw and if i
had to choose
one phone over the other in terms of
speakers it probably would be the
oneplus
and now let's get into the displays the
first thing that you will notice
taking a look at them is the white
balance difference so i do have true
tone turned on
on the iphone it's on by default but the
oneplus actually does
have its own mode they call it comfort
tone so we can go ahead and turn
that on to make it slightly warmer now
the next thing that you probably won't
notice but i do
is the difference in detail the oneplus
doesn't look as
sharp as the iphone but that is because
out of the box
it is not set to the highest resolution
it's just set to 120
hertz so but you can actually go in here
and switch it
to qhd and now we have a very sharp
display that text looks super crisp
and at the same time not only does
everything look
really nice and detailed but we're still
running
at 120 hertz so you can run both
but it gets better than that not only
can everything be super smooth
it can also drop down to one hertz one
fps refresh rate
and that way when you're just sitting
here like this it is saving
battery life which is awesome whereas
our iphone is always stuck at 60 frames
per second
as far as viewing angles they are very
close the oneplus might be
slightly better and if we go ahead and
max out the brightness
the iphone is brighter but
not by as much compared to the samsungs
that we tested in the past so
those kind of limit manual brightness by
quite a bit now of course
if you set both to auto brightness
they'll be right about the same
and now for the biggest screen test
let's take a look at some
hdr video the oneplus has always
struggled in this category it was very
flat before
so let's make sure we're playing hdr and
look at that
we also have 4k 60 hdr capability
um i think the last time we tested out
the samsung it was at 1440p i'm guessing
that's been
updated now so both are going to be
playing back 4k
60. it looks like as far as brightness
they look almost
identical it's hard to tell a difference
and as far as
sharpness and detail both look amazing
that's probably because they're both
playing back
4k 60. contrast looks excellent on both
it looks like the iphone is just
slightly warmer but this must be
the closest hdr shootout that i have
seen
yet they look you know if i can see the
phones themselves i wouldn't be able to
choose which one
is which so shout out to oneplus because
it's no longer
a dimmer flatter uglier looking hdr
experience
both look fantastic and now it's time to
get into performance and we're going to
start out by doing a 5g
speed test now the oneplus 9 pro
does have qualcomm's latest
x60 modem so that is faster than what
apple offers
but in our last test against the samsung
s21
ultra the iphone for some reason was
still faster i thought it could have
been antennas
so let's get and pop this sim in and
let's test it out
both phones are connected to the same
exact server our iphone has two out of
four bars actually now
one out of four compared to four out of
five on the oneplus
so let's go ahead and start and see what
we get
now we don't have the millimeter wave
here we do have the low band that's
great at penetrating buildings like
this concrete office building that we're
in right now
and wow okay that is a big difference so
it looks like our iphone has 59.4
download here in this building and on
the upload side our iphone
smoked the oneplus what is going on so
we have
59.4 download 30 upload on the iphone
which is
typical but the oneplus has 137
and 2.5 i want to make sure that this is
accurate so i'm going to do one more
test but i'll do it on their roof
and i'll run them one at a time to make
sure that it's
completely fair and not interfering with
each other so outside our iphone
boosted up to three bars out of four and
the one plus
was straight up five out of five bars
and the result that we got was very
interesting uh the download speed was
actually slightly faster on the iphone
and the upload speed was slightly faster
on the oneplus but overall they are
fairly close and i just think i have to
do more testing probably in our full
review we'll talk about it i know
i have some really tough spots around
town that i want to see how well this
doesn't
but overall it just shows us that the
amount of bars that show
up don't really matter and now let's put
the a14 bionic and the iphone
against the new snapdragon 888 in the
oneplus 9 pro now i will say
that the version that i have does come
with 12 gigs of ram compared to six on
the iphone
and then it gets extra storage for a
little bit more money but let's go ahead
and run our cpu test and our scores
are in and i have to say that this
is the best score that i've seen on any
android phone
so far even though the s21 also has
the same processor this seems to be
scoring higher now
as far as multi-core we're seeing
roughly a 15 different so the a14 is
still a beast
it is still more powerful and in single
core
that is where the shocker comes in at
about 42
faster for the iphone now the question
is
do you need that extra performance
doesn't really matter well in day-to-day
use just using your phone
the oneplus actually feels faster
because of software but if you're gonna
keep this phone for
three four five years that extra
performance is definitely going to come
in handy so now let's go ahead and close
this let's open up gfx bench
and here we go the test is done and just
like i
expected the a14 is the winner
we have 39 frames per second compared to
28 so that's roughly
40 more frames per second but once again
i have to say does that actually matter
in the real world because as we know the
iphone
with all that power heats up quickly and
then your screen can
dim you lose performance whereas the
oneplus 9 pro
it has a large vapor chamber cooling
system
so in the real world it's going to be
interesting to see
how they actually compare in terms of
gaming so vadim is actually going to be
doing a real world gaming test
comparing both of these and seeing which
one is better so if you guys want to see
that
and our full review go and click that
subscribe button down below and enable
those notifications
and now let's talk about what oneplus
was pushing the most
and that is their new camera system
once again cameras were something that
oneplus was behind in for
years and they're saying they've really
stepped it up they actually are doing a
150 million dollar partnership with
hasselblad
to help with our cameras thanks mkbhd
for giving us that info that is insane
uh so let's talk about these we have our
main sensor is a 50 megapixel not 108
down to 50 compared to 12 for apple but
you guys let me know which one of these
shots
looks better to you now along with that
what i'm most interested in is the ultra
wide
the ultra wide actually the ultroid is
50 the main is 48
so 50 megapixels again compared to 12
and that can over sample or shoot an
actual 50.
this here this one here is over sampled
let me know which one looks better to
you guys
and then for the third camera that is
just a 8 megapixel so a big
difference big jump there it is a 3.3
times zoom instead of 2.5
and here's a sample shot for you guys as
well now we also have a laser autofocus
compared to lidar
and they actually have a 2 megapixel
monochrome
camera which is really weird you
actually can't take photos with that
it just helps the main one now of course
we also have the front facing camera
that is a 16 megapixel uh but it is
fixed focus so if you're focusing
closely like i am in this shot
here you might actually be out of focus
so let me know down below which one
looks better
now of course we can't do a great job
testing cameras just here in this room
in our hands-on comparison so i've been
actually going out and shooting photos i
have a bunch of them ready
and vadim and angelica are going to do
another blind camera comparison
with the iphone and the s21 ultron we're
gonna see
does this hasselblad logo actually mean
anything in a wide variety of situations
and bright sun
at night time and we're going to test
out a bunch of different
diff camera modes it's going to be lots
of fun it's going to be interesting so
make sure you guys are subscribed to
check out that video that one is coming
out tomorrow
and now let's talk about the prices and
our final
verdict our iphone comes in like usual
for
eleven hundred dollars whereas the
oneplus they
actually have upped the prices the most
expensive oneplus ever
but it is a thousand and sixty nine
dollars a little bit less expensive but
that doesn't tell the whole story
the oneplus does come with that ultra
fast charger
in the box it also comes with double
the storage and double the ram of the
iphone
for about 30 dollars less so you
definitely are getting
more bang for the buck and with that
said if you are not
locked into ios the oneplus
is definitely the better flagship in the
past they've always had downsides
now we finally have wireless charging
that is insanely fast
great battery life an awesome display
great speakers that 120 hertz
i really don't know what to complain
about it's comfortable on the hand
i guess it really was going to come down
to the cameras which we will see
in tomorrow's video of course you guys
let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below we do
have links to both of these in the
description
click that circle above to subscribe and
check out one of the great videos over
there
that's been max and we'll see you in the
next video